the 1986 movie Wildcats was a fish out
of water comedy about a woman taking
over as the head coach of a ragtag high
school football team as one review read
it's about a team nobody wants to coach
stuck with a coach nobody wants to hire
36 years ago that was pretty much how
female football coaching was viewed in
the years since we've seen doors open
and attitudes change this NFL season
started with an unprecedented 15 female
coaches the same changes can be seen in
college football albeit a bit slower
with about 3 000 assistant coaching jobs
out there in division one there are just
a handful who are held by women we
caught up with two who know there needs
to be a first to have the next and we
went to find out how they were able to
break through
[Applause]
[Music]
it is kind of surreal that this is what
I do for work because I was always going
to be a coach just I didn't know it was
going to be football for a really long
time Brown University's quarterbacks
coach Heather Marini grew up in rural
Australia in her words a long way from
American football it's sports that's a
different story
I played everything I possibly could in
school from tennis and badminton to
being on the swim team but American
Football was not a part of your
childhood it certainly was not I didn't
see football for the first time until I
was 18 years old and started dating my
now husband who played what did you
think of it the first time you saw it uh
it was the craziest Squad I'd ever seen
and I was not going again
but like her future husband with
football it was a marriage meant to be
mourini became a student of the game
first coaching with Australia's under 19
team then playing with Australia's
national team and now with the Boston
Renegades in the Women's Football
Alliance it really was you know
a combination of it being all the sports
that I knew and just all rolled into one
as well as this curiosity of the
Tactical aspects of football
Mourinho found that being a woman wasn't
seen as a hindrance but an unexpected
asset
more accurate here and there you would
have a new parent come down and they're
like wait This Woman's gonna bust my son
around for a couple of hours yeah but
then I would have a parent of a
returning player who would turn around
be like oh no no no like she's going to
be the best coach your son's ever had
like just wait you know how effective it
is in recruitment kind of surprised me
there is kind of a dynamic where the
moms of these players really like to see
it that positive impact is something
brown head football coach James Perry
has seen a side of with Mourinho part of
his staff for three seasons I think they
like seeing their sons gonna have a
staff that has a lot of different
viewpoints and ideas and in this case a
woman on the staff it's pretty
transparently obvious to me that helps
us in recruitment your ball handling on
it was great Perry first met mourini at
the NFL's annual women in coaching Forum
in 2017 the next year he hired her as a
quality control coach
in 2020 she took over as quarterback's
coach the first female position coach in
division one football
has Heather made your team stronger in a
very real way and it's I think the
quarterback room it's especially true
because when quarterbacks are coached by
a couple different personalities it's
always most effective she does much more
if not better as far as game planning
and really breaking down film Jake
Wilcox was Brown's starting quarterback
this season do you think there's one
area of your game right now that you
think she has really helped you with the
most definitely yeah
um I would say my footwork is the
biggest thing
well mourini may be just another coach
around here she knows to the rest of the
football World she's anything but
foreign
the responsibility I have in my role to
show that women can do this job and be
successful at it is you know it's a lot
but I know that because I'm the first
there'll be more after me and there'll
be a lot of women you know that have
this opportunity you know if I can do a
great job
women like the University of Michigan's
Mimi Bolden Morris in college sports a
grad assistant who in boulden Morris's
case works with the Wolverines
quarterbacks it's a position she admits
she didn't always see herself in I can't
think of a woman who would have even
been in a coaching position when you
were a kid that you would have seen no
none my dad was my brother's coach my
whole life I was his water girl but I
didn't really think that would be my
thing I thought I was going to be a
doctor but as a kid football was
definitely in her blood her younger
brother Mike currently a star defensive
end at Michigan remembers his big sis as
his flag football quarterback what's her
arm like oh she's a rocket did she
always as a kid she had a rocket over
the arm I want her to be my quarterback
my mom won't let her
all the girly stuff but she wanted to
play football Mike said he wanted you as
his quarterback but Mom didn't want you
to keep playing no she didn't my dad
would let me play quarterback and my
brother's practices and she wasn't
having it she wanted me to be her mini
me but bold and Morris stuck with sports
earning a basketball scholarship to play
at Boston College for three seasons
followed by Georgetown where she'd lead
the Hoyas in scoring her final year I'm
gonna stick with the zone you have to
mark her at all times there's Milan bold
and Morris while still playing
basketball at Georgetown Bolden Morris
set her sights on coaching football
that's when her mom stepped in my mom
reached out to Coach Harbaugh your mom
who you just moments ago described it
was the dance team the cheerleading yeah
your mom reached out because your
brother was playing and I didn't know
until I got a call
from coach and I was like
what after like a bunch of conversations
kind of testing my knowledge seeing what
I was doing at Georgetown and he asked
me to be the ga and I was like oh my
gosh I was so speechless
um
and I mean here I am Michigan head coach
Jim Harbaugh remembers the calls he says
Bolden Morris stood out for her work
ethic and drive to get in the game she
didn't even tell me this I found out
from the georgetown's coaches that she
was volunteering on the Georgetown
football staff right she just wanted to
be ready she's not scared she's been in
pressure situations she's got a great
Focus but also a looseness of somebody
that's actually been there and done it
right and has her own ideas I love it
when she you know coaches why are you
doing it that way don't you think this
way might be a little bit better for
bold and Morris it's how she's always
been and she knows with her success
others will have a chance to follow I'm
excited because like there's a whole new
mind to mine gold from that right I
didn't know existed and the great thing
is Mimi turned us all on to that
possibility what does that mean to know
that just by being here you're already a
role model for so many I'm just so
blessed that God put me in this position
to be able to inspire and my only hope
is that by me doing what I'm doing it
inspires others to do what it is that
they want and know that they can
let me be clear here with Mimi's mom
she's 100 behind her now and she said
she lets her be her now so that's a
beautiful thing and you talk to these
players it's so clear whoever makes them
better in whatever way that's what they
want I'm old now I'm realizing it really
is about the best person does not matter
man woman blue green whatever it is
couple that pace and repeat great story
yeah